the musical score of a motion picture
can invoke a multitude of feelings the
fear of unseen Danger
[Music]
excitement of death-defying action
the hell no when Lydia Tarr sees a
replacement conductor
the terror of mispronouncing the
Banshees of Innis Sharon on National
Television
and the horror of a movie star the
horror of a movie starting and realizing
that I left my phone in the car yeah
yikes
[Music]
here are the nominees for best original
score
All Quiet on the Western Front by Fall
Care Bear to mind Babylon by Justin
hurwitz the Banshees of innishairen by
Carter burrow everything everywhere all
at once by sanwas the fablements by John
Williams
and the Oscar goes to alcohol
[Music]
man
[Applause]
vocab bertelman discovered piano at the
age of nine and formed his first rock
band at 14. while in school he began
studying medicine and then switched to
business economics
well thank you so much thanks to the
academy for this huge recognition
um when I was working on the film
I was thinking a couple of times of my
mom because she was telling me
every now and then when you wanna
change humanity and empathy in the world
you have to start by yourself
and with your own surroundings
because you
learn by that and you can show
actually where we all how we all can
live together so you know by working on
a film like that you always
are deeply touched and sometimes you
have to make the screen very small
because there is so much
explosions happening
um
I want to say thank you to my wife
Elizabeth and my kids up there Lotte
Paulina and Lucas
to Malta grunard and Edward Berger and
the whole cast and crew for their
amazing craftsmanship
um to Netflix for their huge support
and to my fellow nominees
Carter
John
Justin son Lux
for that I can be a part of such a
um unique human
and diverse group of talented composers
that's for me a big gift
and last but not least
I want to thank all of you for this
wonderful evening thank you so much
foreign foreign